[Music]
welcome to another episode of
congratulations
crazy
crazy
it's episode number whatever it is i
don't ever really know i know there's
200 something but uh that's it
uh
we
are now you know it's been uh honestly
the uh the podcast has been doing really
well it's been getting higher and higher
uh clicks and views and now we got that
new um podcast called lifeline with me
and my brother out on the same channel
so subscribe to this channel if you're
not and you can get that podcast too
it'll be notified when it comes out um
and um
let me do some uh well okay so i'm do
i'm gonna be in phoenix so i've added
another show in phoenix uh the second
show in phoenix that i'm doing uh
celebrity theater april 30th
so get your tickets at crystalia.com
there let's fill up that second show and
uh all the babies come out and we're
gonna have a good time uh we loved it i
just did irvine and it was really great
um
3 000 of you came out so uh i'm just uh
i'm so i feel a lot of gratitude but
before i get into that um
yeah we got merch crystalia.com go for
all your merch get that oops grenade
merch the uh the don't push me [ __ ] i
wore that on my irvine show that [ __ ]
actually looks very nice that's a very
americana vibe with the hat too
um so you can go and support the show
crystalia.com get some merch pick uh and
uh pick your favorite [ __ ] and get some
merch and that always helps uh you
you know that just basically funds the
log cabin right it funds the gra it
funds the the landscaping bill outside
of the log cabin in the green grass
right it funds the the grass being nice
and tall and luscious and and uh and uh
you know well we when we sit around in
white sharing ideas um but yeah dude
um
you know
i'm feeling okay i actually feel really
nauseous there's been a heat wave and
then it got cool again so i wore a
sweatshirt when it's hot out and a
[ __ ] t-shirt when it's cold out
because i never know what it is and i
always go with the day before and i
should actually go open a window and i
don't but it's all good um and you know
we're keeping it nice the temperature is
good in my house so i'm happy you know
um and uh i've been nauseous i've been
nauseous every other day for no reason
yes dude oh he's been nauseous for
[ __ ] every other day
why who knows he drinks too much coffee
but will he stop
no we won't stop because he needs to
drink coffee because he may get nauseous
but if he stops drinking coffee he gets
a headache oh he's got a caffeine
addiction among other addictions oh he's
got so many addictions and it's all good
but he's got so many addictions
it's a good thing you never tried to do
to do weed or do meth or do [ __ ]
cocaine because oh my god you see so
much bolivian marching powder marching
down his nose oh my god you'd see so
much dude i would show up with the
[ __ ] like i was eating a [ __ ]
crawler
to every er just meetings people be like
what's going on i'd be like nothing just
eating donuts why what's up just eating
donuts
is that coke no i was eating a jelly
powdered [ __ ] donut which is what i
said whoa let's get going on this
[ __ ] meeting um
so yeah dude the world is healing i know
russia and ukraine are at war but the
world is healing
and uh let me tell you why it
uh the world went to [ __ ] i think
honestly the world went to [ __ ] again i
mean 2020 was bad but then also 2021 was
bad but then now it's 2022. and uh
i mean i was josh safty's muse when he
wrote on kajal right and that happened
so and i know i'm late on this this
happened a while ago right this happened
what [ __ ] in march and it's april
this happened in march or something
but you can't just say honda charms
right
this is k by the way this is this is
definitely why kanye west broke up with
julia fox because she said hank chops
and i know everyone is on [ __ ] ticket
twitter and all the [ __ ] making fun of
it and i skipped over it because i was
like i'm not sure but it keeps on
[ __ ] tugging in the back of my mind
doesn't it
doesn't it are you like me do you get
hung up on something do things get stuck
in your mind like it's a goddamn song
but really it's just something that
somebody said or it irked you right you
get a hankering to bring it up on the
episode and i did i finally did do it
why because she [ __ ] said i was josh
safty's muse when he wrote uncut
dude
but what is amused is what she asks but
what is a muse is what she asks and then
julia fox took it back the most
egotistical way and said well i was i
was josh
but that's not necessarily the
definition of a muse is it no but
times oh look there's one good gems in
there okay
it's like my old manager look uh oh look
look yeah yeah you know the music in
there he obviously had a mute okay it's
fine
but talking like that is crazy it's like
beyond valley girl it's like beyond
valley girl and then i i don't even
understand
[Laughter]
han ka charms
hanukkah jams is what she says hanukkah
jams dude
don't know how it goes
did like that [ __ ] old uh what was it
what was the [ __ ] old in living color
when they would go ha ha
have uh tortilla dude [ __ ] david
allen girl is so funny dude he is my
muse and on kachams
anyway dude she really said that [ __ ]
that way she really said that [ __ ] that
way if she was a [ __ ] if she was the
baller she would capitalize on that
she'd come out with hanka cham's [ __ ]
makeup or something
honka cham's a [ __ ] or just hunk of
jams the new [ __ ] now that's that's
what i call music
new honda jams hanukkah jams from julia
fox new
honda jams
good jams
and it would be like all [ __ ]
music that was just
really hot jams it would be like y'all
gonna make me lose my mind up in here up
in there that one would definitely be on
there
dude every now that's what i call music
we had [ __ ] that song from dmx on it
i don't even care if it came out in the
80s now that's what i call music
not now han could j hot han good jams
grooves in the heart
crews in the heart
hanukkah jams
hot hon could gent pop up power 106
honka jams
dude i always like that [ __ ] uh on
power 106 i don't even know if it's
around anymore because i have sirius
because i don't [ __ ] listen to the
radio anymore because the radio has ads
and i want to listen to ads
[ __ ] yeah 2022 that's when we live in
and uh so
so the [ __ ] power 106 like there was
i remember there was a song i never
forget it man you never know when
something's gonna happen that's gonna
that's gonna that's gonna take you
you're gonna take with the rest of your
life right like you're just riding along
having a good time or a bad time you're
just chilling then all of a sudden
somebody says something or somebody does
something and you're like hey get on in
here and be with me for the rest of my
life right and i'm [ __ ] driving along
at life and i'm having a good time and
power 106 says power 106 power power 106
world premiere power 106 world premiere
power 106. and the world premiere was
get your head out yes playboy was the
song which i [ __ ] don't even know
what that song is at this point this is
like 20 years later but it went like
this get get your head out get get get
your head out your ass playboy
dude don't get the whitest guy ever to
do it or do but if you do
no deep down that's what you're doing
and own it because power 106 was still
back then trying to appeal to the
[ __ ] suburban whites trying to
[ __ ] be and honestly that's a little
bit racist that's a little bit racist
get a guy who's actually [ __ ]
talking
to someone saying get your head out you
ass playboy to do the promo otherwise
you're whitewashing it so we figured it
out and honestly we solved the word we
solved racism now we do it 20 years
later but it's fine we do it
get get your head out your ass pop power
106. get get yeah what world premiere
get get get out get your head out ass
playboy why why does why is this stutter
you know
power 106.
every time i would and i've kept that
with me for the rest of my life dude
sometimes just i'll be driving along and
i'll just go get get your head out yes
playboy so
that's fine that's my mind and i feel
like you have stuff like that too han
kachams and that's one of them once you
said that i go like this get in here
and i and i stayed driving and now i got
papa power 106. get get your head out
your ass playboy hanukkah charms
30 of this podcast so far has just been
sounds anyway that's fine dude it's fine
this [ __ ] chick though i never really
did a deep dive with this chick and it's
un [ __ ] believable dude this girl is
unreal in the best way but i can't like
i okay so here we go look we're gonna
watch this [ __ ] right here
she goes like this
what do you want to do that's your dream
project oh my god my buck of course
first of all it sounds like every
chicken ella go ahead
yeah
well i don't want to give too much of it
away because oh you don't want to give
twitch away because it's you don't know
what to say about it you know what i
mean you don't know because it's not
really fleshed out and let me guess let
me guess you don't know what to say
about your book
because it's not really fleshed out why
because you're not a writer why because
you're just an actress but really why
you're writing a book because you dated
kanye
sad
sir
capitalizing on a moment dude
very super
superstitious
[Laughter]
stop let's go back a little bit super
stitches now listen obviously she just
misspoke and that's fine dude that is
fine so she corrected herself saying
superstitious okay don't i don't like to
speak of things before they're finished
but guess what though guess what about
superstitions guess what they don't
exist right you ever walk under a ladder
and then your dad died no and even if it
did it wasn't because you walked under
the ladder i still don't walk under the
ladder just in case there's some other
[ __ ] sort of message
so far masterpiece
[Music]
about your own book that you didn't
write and you're not a writer ha robert
frost turned over in his grave
robert frost won't suck you know um
rubber frost
robert frost palms you know what do you
want to do that's your dream project oh
my god my guy clear your throat first of
all anything you want to do this [ __ ]
cirrhosis of the liver i don't know what
you're about to die from [ __ ]
cirrhosis of the liver hey anything you
want to do anything you want to do
what's wrong with everyone dude this is
variety you know
anything you want to do
wow
hanka jams if i ever heard one you know
what i mean
it was like a memoir but now this is my
first blah
dude it's [ __ ] honestly not um
not good to buy her book okay
let's just be real okay
let me tell you let me go on let me go
out on a limb here that i'm pretty sure
about
you get her book you piece of [ __ ] right
you're the first to go ain't that right
you're the front line you're the guy you
got if there's ever a war of the worlds
you got to be in the front line so you
get ratat and we all [ __ ] figure out
what to do in case the [ __ ] goes down
and our plan is wrong right
if we have a fr you're the frontline you
buy julia [ __ ] fox's book you're in
the front line that's what's up you're
the front line in case we have a war of
the worlds and our plan may not work
right that that all stud it up in your
body dude and you die and then we
reassess the situation and we go [ __ ]
man we have so many casualties and say
yeah but it's cool because really we
only lost the people in this world who
bought julia fox's book
what was the oh my god who was that no
no julia fox from you talking about
julia fox from pretty woman no that was
julia roberts who you talking about oh
you're talking about zastavsky's moves
and [ __ ] hank charms
anyway dude
it's kind of a mastermind
[Music]
what if that's what it did
after the end of every [ __ ] one of
her sentences
you know i was josh safty's meals and
uncharted
[Music]
wow dude this podcast has only been 35
sound so far but it's all good
we did irvine last week and it was great
dude and i say week because it was
cristalia and friends we had gabby lamb
we had uh eric griffin mike linocchi
we had [ __ ] we had different people too
who else did we have actually we had
adam ray
um and we
had hormoz rashidi and we had some good
people on the show it was really fun man
we had a really good time i love doing
those shows man 3 000 of you came out we
did six shows would have done a sunday
but there was a [ __ ] british comedian
that had the sunday show and he sold it
out and i'm sure he killed it and that's
great props to him but i wish i did the
sunday show would have had two more with
the donate shows but it's all good
because i got oh i'm doing a show in
hollywood actually coming up uh april
27th uh crystalia and friends i'll be at
the hollywood improv get your tickets
there but yeah man i'm just getting
ready for this phoenix show really
chrisleya.com for tickets crystalia.com
for tickets um so we did irvine it was a
lot of fun we went out we got the new
with chris video out there on the uh the
irvine with chris on the road with chris
and um i had a good i had a good time
man i really mean irvine is just a great
[ __ ] place to do stand-up huh just
[ __ ] super white super asian and
that's it that's it everyone else just
drives by or is on my show eric griffin
honestly what race is eric griffin first
of all but second of all he's the same
race as the rock whatever that is but
second of all dude
it's unbelievable how white and how
asian
irvine is i don't understand why it's
only white and asian but hey look it's
all good white nations were at my show
and there were very very few others and
that's fine dude we're a melting pot
even if we aren't with our skin we are
with our minds because we have really
great ideas and we love each other and
there's no racism at my shows okay
um but we did irvine and guess what
happened dude
we did irvine
i got out of irvine late at night
with the my my my buddy uh cy right he's
a great guy
packed up the car drove home saturday
night ended the shows it was about 11 30
right
[ __ ]
started the car
you know it's real throaty right like my
[ __ ] is just so throaty it's crazy you
know what i'm saying
i know i have car i have a car that
isn't so authority but that's by design
right because it's a little eco-friendly
but i've also i took the throaty mobile
didn't i this time i took the throaty
mobile and it looked you know it's nice
it's sleek it's black and it was super
clean today too plus i got the clear bra
[ __ ]
and it's not so eco-friendly but it's
black on black on black oh my god dude
and it's low how low is it it's
practically underground dude is this
what the [ __ ] did we start digging
when we're sitting in the car we look at
each other we go did we start digging
why because are we underground no and
then i started up and you go does this
car have a neck and we say why and then
somebody in the back says cause it sure
sounds throaty
i start it up and and it goes
right and all of a sudden someone's like
who who [ __ ] invited the rough riders
right now so i pull out
okay i pull out of the irvine improv and
i do
right
and i [ __ ] you know what i mean like
the back tires have to catch up to the
front because that's just how i drive
right when i pull out of a good weekend
and so i pull out and i go the wrong way
because no matter what i do no matter
how many times i play irvine improv at
the irvine spectrum no matter what when
i pull out i don't know where i'm going
i don't know where the five freeway is
i don't know where the five freeway is
and when i get off the fry freeway and
when i get to the urban spectrum i don't
know where the irvine improv is so i'm
[ __ ] traveling around trying to find
the [ __ ] right
so i get out the irvine improv and i
[ __ ]
right and i'm trying my back wheels are
trying to catch up to my front wheels
right and the car is acting real throaty
you know we're above some shoulders in
this [ __ ]
and so i go
the wrong way i realize i go the wrong
way because i click it into the [ __ ]
what do you call it um
what do you call it the [ __ ]
navigation now guess what we do know
okay spoiler alert navigation systems
when a car's real throaty navigation
systems and the [ __ ] and the
technology inside the car when a when a
when a car happens to be throaty as [ __ ]
the technology in the car takes a back
seat right because these cars are known
for being throaty okay
so when you start a car the louder it
goes the more lost you might end up
getting because the technology isn't
there and that's fine
because we got the technology in the
other car with the bloody guts
okay
so i go the wrong way
i'm throaty all over i'm trying to get
to the five i got to take a u-turn and
guess what your boy does in the throat
mobile guess what your boy does in the
throat mobile he doesn't [ __ ] he
right like especially late at night when
no one's around if the red light is a
red light especially if it's an arrow he
kind of disobeys it and he just keeps
going right because nobody's around and
it's not even a true red light it's one
of those arrow red lights which is kind
of [ __ ] they're kind of [ __ ] right
because you should know when you're able
to take a left or not right i don't need
the [ __ ]
whoever operates traffic lights like the
government telling me you know
so
i have to take a u-turn i make an
illegal u-turn and all of a sudden
behind me it's christmas
it's christmas dude twinkle twinkle
behind me i see and i don't feel
anything man i don't feel anything i
don't think it's because i'm a sociopath
but it's because i'm i haven't got a
ticket in a while right
now i don't know if you know this about
me but in my early 20s to my late 20s i
would get a ticket almost
almost every two months and it wasn't
because i was speeding sometimes it was
because i was speeding but sometimes it
was because i was doing something stupid
like texting with my phone or doing an
illegal u-turn or something drifting i
would drift a lot dude i drift so much
because i drive a lot of late at night
[ __ ] and you know you're not gonna hit
another car so i drift right
it was tokyo drift but very very slowly
for me right i wouldn't go very fast but
i would drift it in now like i was just
kind of like getting to the racetrack
tokyo drift on the way to the racetrack
so
i got lots of tickets in fact i got so
many tickets and i would pay them all
and i would never go to court because
i'm not going to do that right
i would just pay the ticket and then
what would happen was one time
i found out that my license was
suspended but i found out it was
suspended for six months but i found out
seven months later so a month
before that it had been reinstated and i
had no [ __ ] idea dude
dude i had no idea i didn't have a
license for six months and i was still
[ __ ] keeping it i was still in my car
i was still in my car driving to
different places dude i had no [ __ ]
idea if i got pulled over i would have
been coughed up dude and walked away
i had no idea i didn't have a license
but i kept driving anyway and thank god
i didn't get pulled over that boy but
anyway i get pulled over again now i
don't feel any a type of way about this
maybe like 30 because i'm a sociopath
but also 30 because i know i haven't
gotten a ticket in a while and they're
not going to revoke my license and i've
also got a thing in my back of my head
when this guy pulls me over i wonder if
you can be a nice cop
cause i'm super nice when the cops show
up right
i'm super nice
i don't say [ __ ] like yeah officer i say
hey man i'm sorry dude so the guy rolls
up
and i say to see why i say roll down the
window because they [ __ ] it's tinted
i don't want to get a picture for you
know i got to keep it tinted it's a
throat mobile right so
so the cop shows up and he says he leans
in and he leans in and he takes a few
extra seconds to even talk so i'm like
oh [ __ ] i have no idea what's going on
right like usually they come up and
they're like licensed and registrations
they're like hey do you have any idea
what you were doing he shows up and he
waits a few seconds
and he says
is this the bloody guts mobile
[Applause]
the ocpd there's some babies
we've got some blue bl we've got some
blue babies out there near the beach
[ __ ]
guess what it's sergeant baby in it oh
god it's sergeant elder baby in it oh
he says this is the bloody guts mobile
and then i go like this ah get out of
here man
and he says yeah man i said no get out
of here really you know my [ __ ] and he
said i was at the show on thursday oh
god he saw me level a room two nights
before
i wanted to be like were you
one of the people that stood up
afterwards
so that's what he says and i say oh man
and i [ __ ] felt bad i felt extra bad
i really did i felt extra bad because he
now is obviously in this position where
he's like [ __ ] if he's gonna give me a
ticket he's obviously gonna feel bad
because he likes my comedy and [ __ ] so i
said to him right there i said listen
man
i understand if you got to give me a
ticket i know i did an illegal u-turn
and it was [ __ ] and it was wrong and
i'm sorry and he said you know what
and he looks out he's like i'm actually
on my way to another call so just keep
it safe huh and i said
okay
[Music]
in the throat mobile
dude [ __ ] yeah man
yes got into that one dude
it's the only time it ever worked and
then guess what dude i'm coming back
from the coffee bean today oh is this
is this what i think it is chris yeah
yeah it is guys
i'm coming back from the coffee bean
today and i'm [ __ ] driving next to
three
cop cars now why are they in a row i
don't know but the thing about cops
being in a row is you know that they're
not gonna pull you over because they
feel badass driving together okay
so i'm driving next to the cop car and
i'm doing the thing where i'm like well
look you know i don't know if i don't
want to speed i don't want to go too
slow right because i don't want him to
because one time a cop pulled me over
for driving gingerly he said hey do you
know why i pulled over i said no he said
well you were driving rather gingerly
and then i was in my head i was thinking
oh that's okay isn't it isn't it and
then i thought maybe it's not and then i
actually thought do i even know what
gingerly means like i had no [ __ ]
idea what was happening and he said no
it's okay i just had to i just thought
you were driving too well that maybe you
seemed to be overcompensating because
you were drunk driving and i was like
hey cop what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] i'm
driving good don't pull me over anyway
it was fine didn't get a ticket wasn't
drunk and was just driving gingerly
and so um
this cop
is driving next to me and i'm not going
too fast too slow i don't even know what
the speed limit is because i never know
what the [ __ ] speed limit is right
who the [ __ ] ever knows what the speed
limit is unless they're looking at a
sign i'm like is it 35 maybe i have no
idea i was on sunset boulevard i don't
know what the speed limited speed limit
on the vote could literally be 25 miles
an hour it could be 70 miles an hour i
have no idea
so he's driving next to me i roll the
windows down why because you know one
thing about my cars to be true is i've
got the [ __ ] windows blacked out
because i don't want people to see that
my car happens to be on its period
okay but i rolled down the windows
because this cop needs to know that my
[ __ ] isn't blacked out because if he
pulls me over i could get a ticket for
my windows being blacked out by the way
i know the oc cop is [ __ ] listening
about how my windows are tinted
sorry right
i know you pulled me over and you
[ __ ] know about the bloody guts
mobile and i know my winded now you know
my windows are tinted even though they
were open sorry right
but um so uh so this co so the windows
are open and the and the cops windows
are open so now he's driving alongside
with me and i'm driving the same rate of
what i think the speed limit is and so
is he because he's a cop and he's a good
guy and he's trying to obey all the laws
because he's a cop because everybody
knows that cops only always obey the
laws
right so i'm driving next to him
and then i slow down because there's a
red light but he's got the right signal
to go right
and i know he doesn't have to slow down
because he's going right and i do have
to slow down but guess what he does he
slows down with me so now i'm like [ __ ]
man what the [ __ ] did the oc cop call
him and say he should have given him a
ticket and now he's gonna do some [ __ ]
with me but he slows down and he says
hey
and i look over and it's like a 48 year
old cop or something
and we're still driving we're not even
stopped yet and he says
just want to let you know man topher
from workaholics is my favorite
character dude i loved it man i've gone
to see a few times and i'm just such a
huge fan and i'm like really man thanks
so much i don't know if you know this
but i got fans from oc to la in blue
[Music]
mobile dude but that one was
eco-friendly right because i had the
bloody guts but unreal dude the [ __ ]
boys in blue
back me up
and we love it jesus christ if we have a
problem with our house we'll call him up
you know what i mean if someone's trying
to break in we'll [ __ ] do it how
[ __ ]
that was legitness
[ __ ] yeah dude
but let me go back to the beginning man
i feel gratitude dude i really do i feel
gratitude i know right now i'm talking
about my throat mobile and [ __ ] but
that's the dumbest thing i have ever
[ __ ] said dude
wow throat mobile is [ __ ] awesome
dude hop on into thr dude imagine you
were single
and you were driving by a club late at
night and there were these [ __ ] birds
just trying to get in right
like these hens just clocking at the
front door just trying to get in talking
to the [ __ ] security just backpack on
it up you know what i mean just out
there [ __ ] with just out there with
the [ __ ] troop right with the [ __ ]
clock to the [ __ ] security and
they're checking the list right the
dudes out there and they're just
[ __ ] right
and then [ __ ] you
throw up in that [ __ ] [ __ ] that seems
underground oh my god and you say
sweetheart
and they turn around and you say
want to take a ride in the throat mobile
and then when they go what you don't
even hear them because you're revving it
up and then
and the back wheels gotta catch up to
the front of you
dude
[ __ ] it he's got the boys in blue
backing him up
so let me go back though i do feel
gratitude right and i know that so far
this podcast has been the opposite of
gratitude but i want to tell you right
now
[Laughter]
yes i do feel gratitude man to all the
people that came out in irvine and
everybody that supports me dude and i
know and you know the numbers in this
podcast they keep [ __ ] rising and you
know i joke around about stacking money
into a pyramid to touch the sky but i
want to let you know that you guys
actually touch me and my soul you really
do just knowing that you're sitting
there listening to me and i know
sometimes you either tweet out my
podcast or tell people to listen to it
because we're doing the colts work right
we're making sure that one day we will
be in that tall grass sharing ideas in a
log cabin and [ __ ] you know what i
mean like making sure that we are this
healthy
uh living breathing connected cult right
and i just i appreciate you guys man i
really do i really appreciate you guys
and i appreciate all the comics that
[ __ ] came out on the shows
i had such a great time
i had a great time
um so that's gratitude dude yeah
i really am i really am grateful i
really am grateful that you guys you
know are with me and you listen to this
podcast and you listen to the new
podcast lifeline with my brother and i'm
grateful for my brother dude
i love it i love life but who gets
pulled over twice and doesn't get a
ticket you know what i'm talking about
how about this [ __ ] will smith band
dude this is the most hilarious [ __ ]
thing by the way the will smith band
like the will smith
all right we've talked about this
already i'm gonna get too into it right
and the last podcast i did about the
[ __ ] will smith smack how will smith
smack chris rock yet one [ __ ] did
stupid numbers right but it's all good
but now there's an update will smith is
banned from going to this this was the
so he resigned from the academy right
which is fine and he kind of like did
the eminem in eight mile where he did
the thing against him before the academy
could do the thing against him you know
what i'm talking about
like he was like all right i'll resign
and that was when eminem went up and was
talking about
the first you know at the end of eight
mile when he was like yeah you [ __ ] my
girl but i'm still here screaming [ __ ]
the [ __ ] the world or whatever the
[ __ ]
whatever that group is called the new
world or the free world i can't remember
but um
and then the guy couldn't freestyle back
right
and uh
because there was nothing else to say
and eminem just shut him down but
that's kind of what will smith did by
resigning from the academy because he's
like look i'm gonna i'm gonna resign and
that's gonna be my punishment and if you
guys are gonna punish me
also fine right
but he took the narrative and the
strength
right there by resigning himself from
the academy
and then
the oscars i'm going to say this so this
is what happened the oscars banned him
from going to the award show for 10
years
all right
now
when i read that i'm like oh he can't
get an oscar for for 10 years and he
can't you know
be up for an oscar for 10 years and the
answer to that is no he can still win an
oscar he just can't go to the award show
so i'm like oscars
that's not a punishment
that's a reward
he can win an oscar and he won't and he
now won't look like a dick not even
going
dude going to the oscars is the worst
part of the oscars
i have friends that have been i have you
know i i've never been obviously even
though i'm [ __ ] a cree even though i
can act my way out with a [ __ ]
you know a jail cell
right i don't even need keys i don't
need that
what what'd you put me in here for i'm
not supposed to be in here oh i thought
this was crystalia but he seems to be
british
can you let me out i've got you you got
a it's a simple case of mistaken
identity oh well and just act my way out
dude
throat mobile's waiting outside
and so uh yeah dude so they said oh you
can't come for 10 years dude that right
at the peak of when the oscars is the
worst [ __ ]
it's ever been
at the peak of the [ __ ]
hollywood and the oscars is the worst
it's ever been and now they're like yeah
you can still get nominated and get all
the accolades and you can drive your
price up as an actor but you don't have
to come to this [ __ ] stupid party
dude that's a favor
you gave will smith a favor dude if i
was will smith i go oh that's good
that's it that's amazing i have to go to
this [ __ ] thing and watch amy
[ __ ] schumer host [ __ ] terrible
hosts host this [ __ ]
that's the best part about
uh the thing as a matter of fact if i
knew
that that was the punishment as will
smith
not only would i have slapped chris rock
i would have went down the front row and
just slapped everybody 20 years 30 years
40 years how long you guys think i'll
live hey
50 years just for good measure i'm
pretty healthy huh
60 years just for good measure i won't
live to be 130 but just in case [ __ ]
smack francis mcdormand 70 years just to
make it
just for good measure for good measure
just down the road down the rows for
good measure for good measure smacking
everyone
gary oldman for good measure francis
mcdormand for good measure brad pitt for
good measure
the deaf guy from that show the good
measure the guy who want the deaf guy he
wouldn't even hear it coming
you know what i mean
wow look at this
let's do some missed connections let's
do them early this time used to miss my
marriage musician and lawyer miss my
married musician and lawyer
well that that that means one thing that
guy's unsuccessful at definitely one of
those jobs you know you can't be
you can't be
a lawyer
a successful lawyer and a successful
musician you know it's just impossible
it's too hard to be really good at one
of those things to be both of them
used to meet up and i have a way with my
hands and quite a mouth on me wow
i never made you angry well that's a
weird thing to [ __ ] lead with
if this piques your interest get back to
me with news about you and your
interests
dude i never made you angry i guess
that's like saying i'm not i am mad at
you you know meaning i like it
oh here's a [ __ ] hell of it hell of a
title curious trumpet mates eh cure
curious trumpet player would be down to
jam oh so not sexual at all imagine you
were like [ __ ] yeah i'ma suck some guy's
dick and then you show up and the guy
opens the door with a trumpet and he's
just like
um and you're like hi yeah i'm here to
get i'm here to suck some [ __ ] and the
guy's just like um
[Laughter]
um what
okay come on in
[ __ ] slobbing on his novelties
best of both worlds dude
um
here's another one
wow so [ __ ]
uh
[Music]
nondescriptive
nondescript burbank meetings
just burbank meetings that sounds like a
[ __ ]
that would be a book of short stories
that you'd have to read in [ __ ] ninth
grade whenever there was an urge we used
to meet at your place in burbank god
burbank is a sexy goddamn place isn't it
for real it's so like out of la but also
what the [ __ ] goes on in burbank for
those of you that don't know burbank is
about 15 minutes away from hollywood and
it's like a lot of families and [ __ ] but
also
like
guys and women who are like single that
are like that are like 40 and like
people live there because they can't
afford it in in hollywood and it's like
what are they doing i bet the underbelly
of [ __ ] burbank is just abs if they
got to do a lot of math i don't know if
it's math or what but
whenever there was an urge we used to
meet at your place in burbank i always
lubricated your tools wow i haven't
heard from you in over a year you had a
couple of dogs if i remember correctly
hit me i mean how long ago was it how do
you not remember i have a bad memory did
i write this hit me up and i will be
happy to bring wd-40 to loosen your
rusted nuts and bolts you know dude
say yes or don't we get it already you
know you don't really need to add the
wd-40 part
it got so specific it's like an r b song
like so specific
r b got so specific
i wanna put my outsides on your insides
like i that would for sure be is that
how is that not an r b song by d'angelo
i wanna put my outsides on your insides
baby
wanna put my [ __ ] outside i wanna put
the outside of my [ __ ] in the inside of
your [ __ ] just oh my god
dude
this part and i'll be happy to bring my
wd-40 to loosen your rusted nuts and
bolts this is shitty to call them rusted
here's another one oh cereal glendora
have you tried o's cereal free your mind
wow
wow wow already
it will bring you to the edge again and
again until the final
x
oh
explosion but it's spelled e x
e-x-l-p-o-s-h-u-n
explosion that's like how calvin would
say
[Laughter]
explosion
feel the vibe and let your journey to
new flavor sensations begin dude this
guy [ __ ] sucks
let me show you the way just relax and
let sensation take you away since they
shun i'll do all the work while you
enjoy the cereal is for women this is
like morpheus retired and became a
[ __ ] perv
the cereal
this cereal is for women only
dude just dudes showing up with a
trumpet hey i'm here for trumpet lessons
and also that cereal
no it's for women only and you didn't
get my thing about the trumpet i wanted
to suck [ __ ]
dude
have you tried o's cereal free your mind
it will bring you to the edge again and
again until the final explosion
feel the vibe and let your journey to
new flavors why is flavor i guess you're
sucking oh yeah because you're eating
the cereal flavor sensations begin
let me show you the way
j just relax this is morpheus dude
let me show you the way just relax and
let the sensation take you away i'll do
the work while you enjoy
the cereal is for women only
these are good dude female college
student i'm looking for an adventurous
female 18 to 22 who would like to earn
an easy 50 bucks by selling me the
panties you're wearing meet up at public
location for exchange okay perv um
here's another one i saw you
that's great that mom grandmom auntie i
saw you and i want to get to know more
of you let's get together and stoke
those fires between those lights
dude
you know
stoke those fires between those legs
dude
so
[ __ ] i love how he says those twice
to put himself at a distance from him
you know what i mean like what a creep
let's stoke those fires between those
legs
sir
dad died early
dude one thing you know about this guy's
dad died before [ __ ] seven years old
you don't grow up that [ __ ] up and put
sex at an arm's length by saying
those fires between those legs unless
your dad died before he won seven
hanka champs
wow
whatever
is what it is i'm gonna go pee i'll be
right back
oh dude my son uh was like missed the
nap yesterday and it [ __ ] him up
completely
although he's never [ __ ] up his
sleeping pattern really and he missed a
nap the other day and then all of a
sudden at like 7 30 usually usually goes
to bed at like eight but he went to bed
but like 7 15 he was like eating turkey
mustard which is his favorite thing to
eat he's always just like tomato dirty
mouth and i'm just like [ __ ] he said
it so many times how come he can't say
turkey mustard yet but he says dirty
mouth and he was eating it and then all
of a sudden he goes peppa pig like he
[ __ ] loves peppa pig dude the guy
loves peppa pig and i'm a little bit
like what can we watch paw patrol you
know what i mean cause like you're a
dude but also
i don't want to be that kind of
overbearing like dude if my son is just
gonna [ __ ] like chick shows and he's
gonna like chick shows and you know what
that's [ __ ] fine
okay
he's watching he's like peppa pig peppa
pig and then so i'm like all right well
we're not going to watch peppa pig right
because i had to watch something to see
a cut of something that i was going to
put out and he was like i don't watch
peppa pig and then i was like hey calvin
look at me and he looks at me with
turkey mustard all over his face and i
said we're actually not going to watch
peppa pig right now and he goes like
this
and just starts crying right and
kristen's like oh you got to go to bed
right and i said do you want to go to
your big boy bed because that's what we
call it now because he doesn't have the
crib he's got that front exposed
and i said you want to go to your big
boy bed and he goes like this
[Music]
and so it was so cute so we took him up
and he went to bed and then i'm [ __ ]
i'm down in my um
you know we got the nan on our phone and
the phone like will alert us when calvin
wakes up but kristen's upstairs trying
to go to sleep and i'm downstairs
watching some crazy like uh unsolved
mysteries type [ __ ] like of people who
like something from the black dahlia and
then another dude who tried to kill
somebody in in uh new orleans like it
was like a series or something on hulu i
watched hulu because netflix cut me out
of a bunch of [ __ ] and so i was watching
that downstairs and all of a sudden
above the [ __ ] um
above me which is calvin's room i hear
go go go go go go and i'm like is the
black dahlia upstairs
and i'm all you know i know it's not but
i'm scared right so i look in the nana i
look at the nana it didn't alert me but
i look in the nanite and calvin's just
like
and he's crying i'm like this
[ __ ] what's up with his sleep so
i walk into the room
you know he's been crying for like 20 30
minutes now so i walk into the room and
i say hey buddy and he goes
and i'm like oh come here
and i sit down next to the [ __ ] crib
and i look at him not the crib the big
boy bed and i look at him and he says
and they say do you want to go see peace
again you want to lay down and he goes
like this yeah
and he goes and he goes to lay down and
then he pops right back up and he goes
and i say do you want to go to mama
dada's bed and he just goes like this
and falls on me and i grab him i say
okay and i bring him in in the meantime
kristin has no idea and i bring him in
and she's looking at me and i say hey
mama and she says oh my god what's going
on i said calvin's not going to sleep
he's crying and [ __ ] and she's like oh
how come the nana didn't alert us i said
i don't know man i don't i don't think
it has anything to do with the black
dial yet but let's bring him in the bit
so we bring him in the bed and he stayed
with us for like a [ __ ] hour until
kristen was like hey i said yeah she
said can you bring him back i can't
sleep
and i brought him back and then he
[ __ ] stayed in the bed and he passed
the [ __ ] out dude and it was so sweet
man because i was laying with him and he
was just looking at me and when i was
looking at him looking at me he looked
like me so [ __ ] much because he was
just like staring and i was staring back
and i was looking at him and i was like
[ __ ] he looks like me dude and then i
was thinking i probably look like me
even more than that like right now
because i'm doing the same eyes thing
like he looked at me so much but i
[ __ ] trumped him with how much he
looked like me that i [ __ ] was like
you know and i was like how much do we
both look like each other right now and
it was so cute man and then he just goes
like this for no reason and points to
the ceiling and then i like put my hand
on him and then he goes like this to my
hand
and takes my hand off it and i'm like
okay
okay what the [ __ ] does he want you know
but it was a beautiful thing man
i love having a son
i love having this [ __ ] this baby's
so so awesome
and then he was in the other room and i
said
today i was like calvin come here calvin
come here and i said what are you doing
and he's like playing
that play with the water i said well
come here show me and then chris was
like i don't think he wants to come
boiling rage all good but boiling rage
but she's right though because i
shouldn't force him to do anything but
also boiling rage right boiling rage
because my dad would have been like yeah
but [ __ ] i want him to come here and
i'm his dad so boiling rage but also
deep-seated issues with my dad but also
boiling rage because a woman's telling
me what to do right so so many boiling
rages going on but it's fine i let it go
gratitude i've got a throat mobile and
it's all good so um
let's look at this clip this clip was
sent to me in my discord so many franken
times that it's unbelievable the discord
on my patreon sent me this link a lot i
get a lot of messages that want me to
watch this video on my patreon
and i think i've seen it before
i don't know this guy's getting arrested
you just assured me that i could speak
you'll sit here
oh so australian
sit here and saw the care
dude what is this guy getting arrested
for do you know
oh get
i mean knows damn well but the only
thing that comes
[ __ ] after under is either water or a
rest and this guy says i'm on the what
you're under arrest a bunch of cops
i love when guys get so cloudy in their
head because i anger that they don't
know what they're saying like when chris
rock got smacked by will smith and he
said we're here to present a documentary
um i wonder what
gentlemen oh this
is democracy oh dude to actually not be
in a play and roll your rs like that and
not be spanish is unreal this as
democracy after that they should have
gave him extra years for real
that's so [ __ ] to do that this says
democracy
dude what is this a [ __ ] christmas
carol
are you screwed
have a look at the headlock here
worst [ __ ]
tutorial video
got your hand off my penis oh my dude
cop grabbing the feel get your hand off
my penis
[Music]
wow
you know
definitely didn't honk his dick
cop just down there yeah get him in the
car get him in the [ __ ] car get him
in the car
get him in the car come on get him in
the car
come on man get him in the car
the bike who got me on the penis got me
on the penis dude
oh it got me
oh it just got me on the penis
oh yeah that just got cop just got me on
the penis
see that
this is the bike who got me on the penis
before
singing
dude a musical this is the man that got
me on the penis
singing a dude why is he
receive manifest
have a look at the headlock here
over there get your hand off my penis
this is the bike who got me on the penis
people
for what reason what is the charge
eating a meal a succulent chinese meal
dude singing
what is the charge eating a male a
succulent chinese male he just crowd my
penis people
oh that's some nice headlocks
oh
how much did you get the worst breath
i see that you know your judo
singing
not judo dude are you waiting to receive
my limp penis how dare
how come
nobody is laughing
how is that possible got your hands off
my penis
i mean this is [ __ ] naked gun
are you in there waiting to receive my
limp penis
i was eating a succulent just so many
[ __ ] adjectives that are like you
know
dude he also how strong was he
19 cops
that guy what was he on [ __ ] pcp
gotcha hands off my lamp
what what was he getting arrested for
he would dine and dash wow [ __ ]
really taking a stand what's the charge
bro who is this guy this guy for sure
oh man oh my god do you know who the guy
is i want to [ __ ] be best friends
this guy obviously he's dead because
this is what was a while ago but i want
to be this guy's best friend dude how
much melody was in that [ __ ]
oh my god this guy for sure did so many
plays
dining and dashing you know
you just assured me that i could speak
wow dude gentlemen
this
is democracy
[ __ ]
john conrad the headlock here sean
connery see that chip over there get
your hand off my penis
a succulent chinese what if that was the
charge sir
you stand before the court charged with
eating a succulent chinese meal
throw the book at him
no more eating succulent chinese meals
in australia sir
your
bail will be
the
district attorney receiving your limp
penis
succulent china
[Music]
hey guys that's the end of the episode
on youtube if you want to go catch the
rest of the episode the uncut episode go
to uh
patreon.comcrystalia and you can also
get the backlogged episodes there's like
13 of them by now uh you can go listen
to the you can go binge those
congratulations uh at
patreon.com we also have the segments
that we do of review mode did some hot
ones recently and also you get behind
the scenes footage of the with chris
videos you know our patreon is pumping
out uh
content and we also got the discount uh
the uh the discord where we chat and
stuff every now and then anyway guys you
guys are great either way
[Music]
you